[Musique]
la traditionnelle remise de prix du
concours départemental d'élevage s'est
tenu ce vendredi 19 mai à la foire de
Bras-Panon l'occasion de récompenser les
13 meilleurs éleveurs locaux le
département est le chef de fil de
développement agricole de la réunion
nous avons une agriculture familiale qui
fait partie de l'histoire du patrimoine
de la réunion nous avons des filières
qui se sont organisés qui nous amènent
aujourd'hui des produits de qualité et
bien que voulez-vous le département est
fier de son agriculture et nous devons
être là répondre présent pour
accompagner toutes celles et ceux les
femmes comme les messieurs qui
travaillent chaque jour à la terre et il
y en a des familles réunionnaises qui
vivent de ces productions agricoles qui
travaillent dans des conditions
difficiles et bien on accompagne la vie
serait lyonnaise un prix synonyme de
récompense pour les agriculteurs
de joie aussi en même temps donc voilà
voilà ce que représente beaucoup de
sacrifices pour être là aujourd'hui ben
c'est une année de bataille parce que là
il a été compliqué pour l'installation
des bus très compliqué mais après une a
réussi à trouver une solution à dire et
c'est un peu un cadeau d'anniversaire
pour moi parce qu'il fait un an du coup
que mifa
du coup c'est une récompense par rapport
à mon travail et tout le chemin que nous
a fait pour arriver là
là malgré les difficultés du métier la
jeunesse réunionnaise était bel et bien
présente sur cette fois une fierté pour
le département chef de fil de la
politique agricole c'est rassurant c'est
rassurant parce que tous les jours on
parle de des difficultés que nous avons
dans la transmission des exploitations
agricoles et on a vu effectivement dans
cette promotion 2022 de jeunes éleveurs
des jeunes femmes des jeunes hommes qui
se sont engagés dans ces filières
filières d'élevage qui est extrêmement
difficile parce que quand on est éleveur
c'est du lundi au dimanche c'est 7 jours
sur 7 et c'est tout le long de l'année
donc ça montre bien que ces jeunes sont
engagés dans leur exploitation et ils
travaillent pour donner le meilleur de
même et donner surtout les résultats que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui c'est un
travail vers l'excellence c'est un
travail où ils mettent en avant leur
savoir-faire c'est la Réunion qui gagne
c'est vrai mais c'est la réunion qui se
lève tôt
[Musique]